tnvd
and surrender the secret ns system the authorized set
receives information directly from
citizens who call the hotline phone
who call our group of psychologists
who
provide psychological assistance
professional psychologists receive this
information about such crimes but they
cannot disseminate it if the person
does not want to tell about it in order to  everyone
else knew
all the same, the criminals were punished, but
they are not yet ready to give their first and
last name and go to the investigator when
citizens call day and night, it’s
laziness around the clock and say that
they need such support precisely due to the
fact that they were raped by the
number of these  Gareth calls are
massive and we believe that this is a weapon of the
Russian occupier against the Ukrainian
nation, because when Ukrainians,
Russian soldiers rape a Ukrainian
woman, a girl, a boy, into an elderly
woman, they all the time say
that this will be the case with every Nazi
[ __ ], or this is how we will rape
until you can give birth to Ukrainians,
these are signs of the
genocide of the Ukrainian people, here is the hopper
detour of Aigerim, and if
you know now, of course, when the
first calls went off, this work was
seen as a
terrible word in this when applied to
rape, but what are they
that lack of cruelty  it is equally
similar well, for example, if it concerns 1
example, the Buryats are those who were part of
just Buche,
but there are those who raped and then
wanted to get married, but in order to
get married it was necessary to kill the mother, that is, the
woman who was raped, we also
have such cases and
recorded as  since this woman
has already testified, for example, was it worthy
that it was significant that they
grabbed
11-year-old children or 16-year-old girls or a man on the streets, not from home, not from basements, or a
man, well, that is, it was like that with
them, so in this way they raped  and
rachel
weisz himself, this you well, tall enough,
you understand, half a day of age, they
call, basically, mom will give birth
they didn’t eat these children themselves, they didn’t eat them on their own,
for example, in the case of 1 11-year-old girl, she
feels guilty that her mother was not
allowed to go up to 100 miles, and that she
did not let her go outside, but the girl herself
went out because she wanted to make her mother
pleasant to pick flowers  and at that time
she was
met by two people in military uniform,
it’s understandable because there is something
Russian military extinguishing there, they
occupied up to 100 miles of her, they raped her,
that is, there are a lot of children, but we
can’t say what percentage because
we don’t make all the stories public,
but  and
we are doing everything to
record these crimes and so that
those criminals who start Putin are all
punished meet with the investigators of the
international criminal court and we
will understand how we can cooperate in order to ensure
that all these facts that we
have they are as evidence of all these
crimes that have been throughout
eight years makes the Russian Federation
not only from 22 years old February 24 one of
2014 but not  with the difficulty of
personifying the responsibility of the same
Putin, because neither Ukraine nor Russia
ratified the Rome Statute and
therefore we ask that
a special tribunal be organized such
as for example you're being either
Rwanda hatch or Yugoslavia in order to
have an unlimited right to this court and
so that indeed then the criminals
would be punished, but the formation of such a
creation of such a tribunal can be
blocked, and the Russian Federation,
through the kind of UN Security Council, and
therefore now forty-nine
countries have appealed to the international
court in The Hague in order to organize
such a tribunal, and this is already such an
opportunity, you only need  finally, the
political will can be done
if, for example, European countries
unite and this is expressed as a substitution, this is
not an owl and the camera begins to put on a
response